they wanted to sneak up but you don't
sprinkling her down the bottom of this
place where we turned it over yeah okay
look at that Foyle
okay clicking it is really look up
yonder
oh whoa
okay I retook the soil before you start
whacking okay oh yeah a golf glass
covered here we can see evidence of the
mining now this mine closed many years
ago our coverage here my glare so if we
look into the quarry
in the normal daylight in the absence of
the snow it would look a bit like a
lunar landscape Oh the black surface
glares personally I prefer wrong now I
say that for one specific reason because
in during the Apollo program the the
astronauts they came back from the moon
with bucket loads and bucket loads of
moon rock and dust oh very good
and upon analysis they were really
really surprised to find that there are
a number of elements including yttrium
which existed in a much much higher
abundance on the moon which happens to
be the deepest deepest penetration upon
rain so we're in it to be in Sweden and
it's a really nice day and we've come to
the Italy quarry or e2b groover which is
actually the birthplace for for the
elements and really the one we're going
to talk about now is this one here
each reom it was first discovered in
this in this quarry from a really
horrible black lump of mineral which
people thought was cold and over a
period of about 40 years and the late
1700s on some scientists over in our Bo
did a lot of work in refining this
material and they found a new earth or
yttria okay this is it reom and oxygen
and they couldn't get the oxygen out by
using traditional reductive methods of
metal making methods like burning with
carbon and charcoal so the atria
survived and it was known for about 40
years before the german scientist valla
decided to react the atria with much
more reactive element potassium the
potassium wrestled and ripped that the
oxygen and he made it real for the first
time
it's room it's used in a whole range of
different things it's used in super in
semiconductors with this um barium
copper oxides the one two three
complexes as we know of and it's used
for a whole range of different
applications used in laser technologies
to make very intense pulses of light but
for technologies like CDs and LEDs etc
etc but massive massive area another
activity or another use for your trium
is actually any use of the it of each
reom oxy sulphide which is used as an
additive in glass it makes glass really
tough like bulletproof glass it makes it
shock resistant and very very very
resistant towards temperature changes so
it's a very useful additive in glasses
and and glassy materials if you don't
fall over the rock so it really is a
really quite nice lustrous soft metal
from Group three of the periodic table
it burns really readily in an
oxygen-rich atmosphere and reacts quite
well with water in the atmosphere as
well so you have to be very careful with
it room because it oxidizes and it's
really quite easy to destroy that's you
tree of metal just as turnings
so we have to handle this on the
nitrogen which is generally a form an
oxide layer and then you won't be able
to do any chemistry with it yeoreum is
an element which is not again
particularly widely studied in chemistry
much less so than its neighbor Zucco
neom and it's but again it's an area
where chemists now are beginning to
focus on rather more if it's really
finely divided than in my burst into
flames in fact all metals if they're
very finely divided they're quite likely
to spontaneously combust